I'm Alex rosi and I'm an investor and I
own acquisition. comom it's a big
portfolio companies it makes me more
money than I'll ever need rest of my
life I had a 100 business owners who FW
out to our headquarters to scale their
companies and so they ask me questions
for an hour I try to do my very best to
make the solutions as tactical ass
humanely possible so that you can
watching from home immediately use them
in your business first off I have to say
thank you for uh taking me out for
dinner last time that conversation that
we had literally changed my life and
changed my business so um yeah I
appreciate that um can I tell the story
of what happened for sure we had an
event that was scheduled had to get
moved the memo got passed down and
everyone found out except for uh one
sales guy and he sold six people into an
event that didn't exist on like a random
Monday we had six people showing up came
from Israel and he was like hey I'm here
for the workshop and I was like this
looks awesome for us I'm really happy
I'm really happy that we that we're in
this situation we've always tried to
come from the perspective of like when
you when you have something that gets me
up like you can't just like refund
somebody cuz they're still net negative
right like he still flew from his real
if i' said hey my bad here's the money
back he still like screw this guy right
and so we had the team spend the day
with the the six and then we took them
out to dinner and I I bring that up just
because it was a great like example um
of like something that took me too long
to learn was that like you can't just
make it right you have to make it more
than right um in order to actually make
it right you know that was obviously a
super unfortunate situation and you know
every business if you have humans you
make mistakes right and so that was a
mistake that we had made I remember
hearing the stat from Disney which is
that it takes 37 magical moments to
overcome one tragic moment and so the
moral of that statistic is not let's do
37 magic moments it's avoid the tragic
moments if at all possible but if you do
find yourself in a tragic situation
here's an interesting thing that Lila
taught me which is that believe it or
not the people that you wrong and then
Super compensate to make it super
become your biggest ambassadors he flew
back out and he gave such a heartfelt
you know you know story that
like it took somebody who was negative
and I think you know from at least what
it sounded like he was super positive
towards us and I think that that's in
some ways as terrible as it is when you
do have one of those tragic moments just
see it as an opportunity to flip someone
from a hater into an ambassador rather
than being like Oh we got to give these
people refunds it's like no like we
actually get to build a reputation and
decide what kind of company we want to
be we're we're stuck at right now so
we're selling the backend offer 195 a
month um for semi-private okay um or
four months for 5.95 our turn for both
of those is 50% so weighted its 30%
churn and the reason why we've got such
terrible churn is nobody shows up like
7% of our student body actually shows up
to the calls and actually gets the value
from the thing they purchased what's the
onboarding look like so we have the
closer um get them to see the calendar
of we have eight sessions a week that
they can join so they show them the
calendar they say okay which one of
these do you think you can come to and
then they get them to say okay this one
and then the closer says okay I'm going
to tell Jenny who's the coach on that
call she's going to be expecting you
there's two there's two kind of like
different angles to attack this one is
the kind of like logistic side which I'm
going to cover first because it's easy
and just process stuff and the other is
kind of like the bigger Mor morphous
stuff which is like how do I make our
thing easier uh easier and more
enjoyable for people to kind of
experience um on the logistic side I'm
sure that you're on my email list if we
had dinner you better be on my email
list uh by the way if you got anyone
here read the mosy minute anyone I think
it's the best like I some of the best
stuff I put out anyways it's really good
I think it's really I spend like my
Sundays on it um anyways so band famam
is way of life so book a meeting from a
meeting right and so the sales guy
should obviously book to the onboarding
call right or the whatever I do think
that you probably need to add one
onboarding call that's specific to the
person not just have them drop in how
much do you want this to work really bad
okay so this is what I would recommend
doing you'll probably want to do
something in the neighborhood of four to
six sessions that are oneon-one I'm just
being like now if you need to adjust
price in order to do it fine but it's
four to six sessions of one-on-one
before they kind of like qualify to go
into the kind of the group setting and
so it's like you you will personally
onboard them so that they have this way
better buyin they're way like they don't
feel like they're just like in no man's
land and just getting tossed into the
middle of a conversation like you kind
of like on-ramp them after you have the
onboarding which should be and you can
you can cut I mean at the very beginning
just do two you know what I mean just to
start and then you can kind of see how
it goes um from there you basically want
to keep bam faming um per session so all
the people are showing up the last five
minutes I would say okay everybody let's
pull up the calendars when are you guys
showing up again great and I would book
it with everybody so that keeping people
forward and you have to back that up
with probably the reminder sequence that
they're going to get because it's
actually a scheduled session so they
should get automated reminders and they
should probably get a manual reach out
from the person who's running the
session of the people who are supposed
to who are supposed to attend at the
very least do the automated one and that
would probably get a huge amount of like
that will probably do a lot and so this
is actually believe it or not this is an
onboarding process for a gym so if you
have large group training if you take
people and just toss them into the group
it's much harder than having kind of a
more dedicated onboarding experience the
ideal is you do like six one-on-one
sessions with someone they feel more
comfortable in the gym they understand
people they understand how the kind the
vibe the culture is and then they kind
of graduate into the group sessions and
so what happens also is that the group
sessions are now on a pedestal it's like
you're not you're not ready for that yet
right it's like you got to earn that and
all a sudden becomes the prize that they
earned and now they got onboard does
that make sense can you see how that
would work for sure yeah so this would
probably be you set that up as like a
big head longtail sort of pricing system
and the question that you'd ask um if
you want to give an AB close for this
is you would say would you rather train
uh you know start your start your thing
in a group or oneon-one with me that's
if you're selling if it's somebody else
or one-onone with John and they're a lot
of times they're going to be like I'd
rather do it with John and you're like
great so this is the price for that and
then you just go for that sale if it's
not like no worries we can just start
you here not a big deal and then if you
want if normally you sell six you can
say you know what I'm still going to
give you one if you do that because it's
going to be way better an experience for
you so then it feels like a gift and
doesn't feel like they're like well now
well now I don't want the group thing
right so just give them one or two if
you if you sell a six for example does
that make sense so um he presented
obviously with a a low consumption issue
which then probably translated into low
renewal and probably low high turn and
so the the the issue that typically
precedes that is low consumption right
and so in order to first get consumption
you know figured out I like to get
attribution in place and so I don't know
what kind of tracking he had but I think
he said like 7% or something like that
um and so he had some level of tracking
which allowed him to even take action on
the problem but most times when I ask
more questions i' say nine times at
attend the entrepreneur has a problem
but doesn't collect any data that
precedes the problem and so then the
first step is to just go collect the
data and once you have the data
typically the solutions become obvious
and so a lot of time is wasted in this
space of like trying to ideate and
figure out this hypothetical solution
without any data and you're like I don't
know is it this or this or this that we
could do it's like well you have no data
so you have no idea and so you just keep
circling and so when you don't know what
to do get data first and then it makes
the path easy I sell career coaching
services to corporate Executives um so
basically we help these people find
their next role so we did 7.2 million in
Revenue last year congrats about 2
million in profit amazing and um we know
how to grow BC we know that we can do
that but we're really wanting to get B2B
going okay so these Enterprise level
deals are a little bit more they're a
different ball game right okay so we're
struggling to get our first B2B do
because they have to be big enough to
have the budget why do you want to do
B2B so this entrepreneur is obviously
doing well you know he's doing multiple
millions of dollars a year and he's got
something that says decent margins and
he said in order to scale he should do
B2B but he was in a consumer-based
market and consumer markets are huge
there's way more consumers than there
are businesses so he had a proven
product with a proven acquisition
Channel and was profitable and was
growing and he was spending you know $3
or $5,000 a day I was like this is
nothing um in terms of the amount of
scale that's available for the product
that he had and so when he said he
wanted to do this other new thing I had
an inkling that it was for no actual
reason besides he probably encountered
some sort of difficulty that he assumed
the New Path wouldn't have and so this
is just a classic woman in the red dress
why can't you just do more what you're
currently doing we can I mean like we
hit like 980 and uh in October and like
that was a big like a million month like
that was the Milestone where it's like
okay let's start doing different stuff I
I'll tell you what my initial reaction
is what you're already probably guessing
which is like I will exhaust more before
I look at anything new and so someone
would have to make a very strong
argument for me why I can't do more of
what I'm already doing so if I were to
like buy your company tomorrow I'd be
like yeah don't worry about that just
what are you what are you currently
doing to get uh to get customers oh just
Facebook ads okay so what are you
spending a day uh anywhere from 3,000 to
5,000 a day right I'd be like okay so
how do we get to 100,000 a day and
spend a day yeah wow like what stops us
from getting to 100,000 a day okay and
the answer to that question is the con
straint so what stops you from getting
so let's say 10,000 a day so that's a
triple so like what stops you from doing
that we were there in October right
around 10,000 a day and then we had like
sales efficiency issues and stuff like
that obviously Q4 is not like the best
time to have that type of service and so
really just like making sure that our
backend or our front end like sales
called to close rate all that good stuff
is like able to profitable and we have a
lot of like services like one-on ones
that we pay our coaches really well we
have a writing team in house that we pay
so there's there's cost so what would
but that those costs are fixed because
you'd have that cost of the BB right
okay so what stops
US the problems that exist in the BET
Toc scenario also exists in the B2B
scenario and so he's like hey I've got
I've encountered this problem I don't
know how to solve and so my way of
solving it is to not solve it and start
something else that will C create even
more problems in my business and so when
you say it like that it sounds
ridiculous but this is a decision-making
process that or rather a mistake making
process that a lot of people follow
fundamentally you want to ask why can't
we do more and the answer to that
question is the constraint and the only
in my opinion proper constraint for
deciding to uh go after a new Avatar is
that you run out of the existing Avatar
so think about this just have you ever
done B2B like Enterprise okay so the
thing is is that um they are higher
leverage but you're also going to have
like 10 15 touch points and so the
number of deals per guy is going to go
down a lot there's also going to be
multiple stakeholders they have to get
involved on their side and multiple
stakeholders that you're going to
introduce on your side so just in
general for B2B like Enterprise level
sales you increase conversion rate and
stick of a customer by increasing the
number of people that are involved in
the transaction on both sides so
basically you want to show you want to
show as have as many of these ties as
you can to do Enterprise sales the the
lowest risk adjusted return move in any
business is to do more of what's already
working and answer the question why why
can't we do more and so if you have a
sales efficiency issue then like solve
the sales efficiency issue because it's
holding you back from tripling the
things that you brought up are all fixed
problems as in their they're problems on
both paths so to to to forgo the path
you're currently on for A New Path
that's completely unproven with with the
same problems that you know already
exist is a much higher risk move than
just saying yeah why don't we just get
to 30
million okay so just focus on maxing out
B Toc about B2B till we're like fully
confident BC like we're doing everything
well not even that you're doing
everything that you have exhausted the
market of C's okay okay right like it's
so if want diversity then I'd still I
would rather you go diversity of Channel
rather than changing customers the
riskiest thing you can do it's a new
business basically you're have you have
to have a new offering you have new
acquis like everything's new and so I
would rather if you if you have the itch
for new just get a second Channel but I
don't think you're even close to that
you're at 3 to 5,000 a day I think you
can totally spend 50 100,000 a day for
sure just on meta what will likely be
the next uh thing that gets in your way
is that your rowes is going to drop uh
and so typically that's going to be uh
you're going to need to have option one
better lead magnet option two better
creative option three Superior cro
conversion rate optimization just on the
the pages option four improve sales
efficiency option five all four and then
that allows you to scale and like
fundamentally the difference between
companies that can spend 100,000 a day
and 5,000 a day profitably is how good
they are it's literally just making all
of this pieces better and that takes
time because you're going only change
one of those at a time and this is why
business takes time to grow I sell
bleacher rentals to festivals and fairs
so we do around 4 and a half million in
revenue and about a million in uh
profit congrats what's stopping me is
having my leadership team delegate fully
some of their responsibilities and I
think it has to do with um creating
processes that are followed by all if we
need to hire key people and we don't
have the processes then we can't
delegate properly so how do you train
leaders so this this is this is a good
question that I'm going to Chunk Up one
level because I think it'll be valuable
in general um which is that
fundamentally when we're hiring anyone
we look for the smallest skilled
deficiency possible fundamentally you've
got traits as people call them and then
you've got
skills now based on Alex's worldview uh
this is not a thing it's just that a
trait is just a series of skills right
and so when you hire a CFO for example
you're going to try and hire for the
smallest skilled deficiency and so if
the CFO is a dick for example but
they're exceptional and all these other
things then you're like maybe I can
teach them to be kind in these ways now
that'd be a big you it's a lot of skills
to just have some like go from not kind
to kind right a lot of subskills
underneath of that and so if it's two
days to train sales and two months to
train kindness take this person who's
kind and then train them on sales later
on sometimes you have people who you're
like okay this person's a little
different than our Vibe they're not
going to be you know oil and water um
but they have this massive skill set
that we can use and this tiny deficiency
that is around this stuff that we can be
transparent with them up front that they
need to fix I've seen this happen like
again and again and again where a
manager or a leader talks to somebody
else and says hey and then uses a
morphous terminology that's very hard to
pin down to basically say change your
behavior and they're like but how and
they're like change it and you're like
okay I don't know what that means and so
the reason so obsessive about
operationalizing terms like what is
patience what is courage what is you
know what is humility like what are
these what do these terms actually mean
in terms of behaviors like patience is
figuring out something to do in the
meantime like if you do figure out
something to do in the meantime you're
by default being patient right and so
it's telling someone what they actually
have to do not who they have to be stop
being lazy is very hard for someone to
solve it's like I keep telling her to
not be lazy and she keeps being lazy but
you have to break the term down into
what behaviors you describe as lazy cuz
when you talk to you know your your
partner you talk to somebody else you
say hey Sarah's kind of lazy have you
noticed that there are things that she
did that you observe that you ascribe
the label lazy too and so you have to
think more deeply like what did they do
to deserve the title and it might be
like they don't respond quickly to slack
messages these are things that if you
said hey Susan instead of insulting her
and saying hey you're lazy instead we'd
say hey you don't respond to slack
messages quickly enough you aren't
responding you know after hours and our
hours keep going till 9:00 p.m. and
you're not responding until after you
know after 5: and so for this week I
want you to focus just on responding to
slack messages so let's turn on
notifications let's turn it on both of
your phones and and turn it on your
computer so that you can see it is there
anything else that's going to get in the
way of you responding quickly now when
we ask that question we might find out
that Sarah's overwhelmed because she's
doing somebody else's job who we laid
off and we haven't backfilled it's like
okay well now we have context but until
we get to there we can't appropriately
measure Sarah's inherent value or traits
rather behaviors to give her a label so
to your question how do you train
leaders I think that attracting good
leaders so one of it's recruiting right
so um Chick-fil-A's head of people said
this she said a lot of people are trying
to fix process when they really lost the
championship in the
draft and so a lot of people are trying
to to figure out what Playbook they
should be using with a team that's never
going to win so the big framework that
we use for training in
general is document demonstrate
duplicate
and so first you figure out exactly what
the checklist is and I like checklist
more than quote Sops that's a a personal
preference and say like and you want to
be able to break it down into behaviors
and I think this is where a lot of
training goes wrong I think most
companies aren't very good at training
they're just they basically hire a bunch
of people see who's got the skill and
then fire the rest but if you do get
good at training it's like how do you
train kindness well you say okay well
people who are kind when they come on a
phone they they smile right and they nod
their head when people are listening and
they repeat back what someone says and
they you know raise their voice when uh
when uh they walk into a room right and
so if you boil it down to some of the
behaviors then the onus is on us as
Leaders to be more specific with what we
tell our subordinates to do and I think
a lot of times if you're struggling to
train some of these key traits with
leaders it's because you're not being
specific enough about what you want them
to change and so it's like you're just
not getting it it's like well no one can
do anything with that and so it's like
you have to and this is where the work
comes in from the top down we're like
okay when you do this and so the easiest
way to bucket
this that's a p there we go is Sarah I
need you to stop doing this I need you
to start doing this and I need you to
keep doing this and so just being more
granular about what Behavior you want
them to stop or what Behavior they're
not doing that they need to begin or
combination and so um giving someone the
feedback of I need you to do this in
dead of this has been some of the most
effective way that I've been able to
change people's behavior and it's about
around the specificity and so if your
leaders aren't doing what you want them
to do document demonstrate duplicate
this is the step process let me show you
how I do it now you do it in front of me
and this is what we're going to have you
stop doing you're going to now do this
instead and keep doing the other stuff
that's
good I sell professional book publishing
services to entrepreneurs and Executives
we do a million dollars in Revenue I'd
like to be at 3.2 million in Revenue
very precise and I just
32s my favorite number this the best
this is the best explanation for of
Revenue goal I've ever had that's great
what's stopping me is I'm at the stage
where I need to make more money before
thinking about other things and the
challenge I'm facing is a lot of things
have worked for us up to this point but
I need to know what to I need Clarity
around what to do more of so what's the
input so what's the thing that drives
the business the the biggest thing that
drives the business right now is
referrals okay second biggest thing is
related to organic in the form of
speaking social media and guest coaching
and then we have a split between cold
email outbound and Facebook at you're
doing all the acquisition channels all
of them and we didn't even mean to do
all of them we just kind of tried them
all and they all seem to work enough
what's the greatest percentage of your
customers what channel they come from
the greatest percentage of the customers
be after referrals would be organic okay
um and that's now you you put that both
in organic content but also like
speaking and things like that okay how
many speaking things are you doing
online like a monthly basis it's about
one per year last year okay so I have an
idea um so I would I would ask the
question like how like I think I might
have told this in a short but a really
close friend of mine um he took over uh
reel which is a public traded um real
estate brokerage their primary way of
getting more agents is him speaking at
real estate events and so in Q4 he did
66 speeches and um in 24 months he took
from 200 million to 1.2 billion in
Revenue and so he's doing you know 270
plus events per year uh in person we
were having dinner and he was like no
one gets it he was like no one
understands how much more we do than
them and I'm I'm I'm only telling you
the story not to make hopefully it comes
across the right way yeah um because I
think you just you like if if and I'm
guessing if that event generated
business for you yeah I mean every time
I speak we make a significant amount
well yeah so I'd be like let's like how
do we go from you know one a year to one
a week and start there just like Target
50 next year and so he rightly
identified that he simply needed to do
more the next natural question I was
going to be asking is like what are all
the ways to you customers which he
obviously answered and so then it was
like okay the next followup question I'm
thinking is where do we have the most
leverage so either that's going to be
which thing is taking you the least
amount of time that makes you the most
amount of money uh or which one is the
thing that cost you the least amount of
money that makes you most amount of M so
it's either time leverage or it's money
leverage or both now the fact that he
said I always make a bunch of money
after I speak I was like okay that's a
positive indicator and as soon as he
said I only do one Speaking event a year
I was like I don't need to know anymore
like if you're get if if that's a
significant amount of Revenue and it's
one day once a year like I see that and
think okay well we could 50x the
business if we just did 50 of those and
so then the constraint then becomes okay
how do I get booked on these stages but
then that's you follow the same core for
you do the Outreach you post cont and
then you reach out to people to find out
and sometimes you have to pay to be on
the stages sometimes you get a booth and
then they'll give you a speaking slot
there's always ways to get on if if you
need to uh we acquire companies in the
UK and Dubai um current Revenue across
the portfolio is about 35 million the
metric isn't so much want to get to a
revenue metric want to try and create a
minimum of around 50 million Enterprise
Value um do you own all of them out
right no so it's it's varied I think the
problem is do we focus on building out
the double down on the companies we
already have grow eidar that way or do
we keep acquiring and build the eidar
through acquisition how many do you have
14 14 are they similar no that's the
thing so if we was to grow through
acquisition we'd have to try and create
Synergy down a line yeah so you're
you're in a very classic kind of PE No
Man's Land uh so you have more companies
than most funds would ever have
um and you didn't pursue a synergistic
strategy in order to accommodate volume
and so on one extreme you have like
constellation which you're probably
familiar with Canada it's like they only
buy vertically integrated SAS and they
go sub3 million and they just do 100
deals a year right and they just know
their playbook uh on the other side you
have traditional PE that would have a
variety of different businesses they buy
you know detail shop and then a
supplement company and then a whatever
but they only have 68 companies in a
fund and they have a decent you know
decent holdco team to to to add value um
to the company and so if I were in your
position first thing I would do is
probably ask myself who do I want to be
when I grow up in terms of what you want
the actual day-to-day of the business to
be because you can hit 50 on either of
those paths right and so it's which of
these do I feel more like more me like
do I feel like I do have a couple of
these businesses that you're like I
really understand these ones um and if
you don't feel that way then I would
probably look at these and go 8020 and
say okay what's the 20% that's driving
80% of the of the Enterprise Value and
trim honestly I would just like go
completely passive on those ones or just
return Equity or do some sort of deal so
I could get my attention back and then
double down on the ones that you are
good at so this gentleman who had a had
a PE firm uh suffered from a classic
issue that I cover in the offers book
which is that he had not committed to
the niche so this is Page 38 of the book
and I tell the story where um I try not
to Niche slap people which is that they
need to pick one Niche ideally now this
gentleman had basically two paths that
he could follow he could follow a more
concentrated path of just a few
companies that could be desperate or
different in nature but because of a
team of fiveish people he could probably
preside over those call it six companies
that are the the better ones of the
portfolio double down on those inject
Capital bring you know recruit higher
higher level Talent maybe improve the
strategy and then grow the companies the
alternative path um was that he just
gets really vertical meaning he tries to
get as many uh companies that are of the
same type so that he can see
trying not to use fancy words but
synergies between the companies so that
they all together kind of the sum of the
parts is greater than the whole because
you can centralize some costs which adds
profit to all of them you can have cross
business learning so if you have 10 HVAC
companies started by 10 different
Founders all of them are going to have a
few things they do well so you take the
best practices from each of them
individually and then you implement them
across all of them and so you get this
cost savings off the bottom line by
centralizing costs and then you
distribute out best practices is and so
that is a typical uh kind of private
Equity play which is a rollup play where
you can buy 10 things for a million
dollar and sell all 10 together for 50
million and so he was obviously shooting
for $50 million exit and the crazy thing
is and this is true of Entrepreneurship
is there's a lot of ways up the mountain
the bigger the goal is the fewer the
ways up the mountain there are so you
want to get to a trillion dollar company
well there's you have to you're going to
have to do some crazy new technology
that probably doesn't exist um in order
to get there if you want to have a $50
million exit you can do that with just
about any business by just getting it to
a decent amount of size and yes that
includes chains of brick and mortar that
includes online B like you can you can
absolutely do it in any Niche no matter
how small it is I sell health and
wellness so basically Physical Therapy
personal training 35 to 45 year old
athletes okay are is the Avatar and we
do about a little over 3 million the
biggest thing that's stopping me you
have a huge shortage in practitioners um
to give context there's about
16,000 open positions you're Supply
constraint yes so um I need more
producers to produce um so I decided to
kind of pivot and say well if I can't
find the people I'm going to increase
price well I'm glad you did that as as
the thing you decided to do so that's
fine like I started another business on
e-commerce yeah yeah instead of start
teaching people to uh yeah
yeah so that went well to the tun of we
didn't lose Revenue okay um but I'm at
that point where now do I go all in on
continuing to increase price and move
more into almost like a concierge
membership model or do I go all in and
just try to crush and find the people
and do what nobody else is possibly
doing do you have any issues on getting
customers no we have more demand out
that we could book people so um have you
heard my story about uh buddy m is the
cleaning
business all right I'll tell I'll tell
you so um former gym owner uh crushed it
with gym launch and then decided he
started making enough money that he
started investing in real estate as all
entrepreneurs do and then after he was
you know crushing in real estate he was
like you know I should probably start a
cleaning company because he started
doing airbnbs out of his real estate
he's like this is costing me a ton of
money I should vertically integrate and
so he started the cleaning company uh to
clean you know his airbnbs and he's like
well now that I have the cleaning
company I might as well start selling
other C don't want to leave money on the
table right uh and so you can see how
this spindles right the moral of the
story though is that I called I called
him up um and he was telling me he like
dude it's crazy he's like selling
cleaning customers he's like CAC is like
25 bucks it's insane every like it's so
easy to get customers and I was like oh
you should scale this to the Moon he's
like yeah you know it's kind of hard to
get English-speaking Maids who don't
take stuff from people and do a good job
and show up on time and are willing to
work for $115 an hour and I was like
okay so the nice thing that you have is
you have a supply constrainted business
that he was used to Fitness which is
typically demand constrainted so it's
just it's it's hard to get people who
want to show up to the gym right uh not
hard to get people to say they want
somebody else to clean their house um
and so basically the reframe that I gave
him is what I'll give you which is
you're not actually in the physical
therapy business you're in the
recruiting physical therapists business
the whole Paradigm that I would have
around this is what do the career path
look like for the physical therapist so
that I can make this really enticing on
top of that I have to still think
through the same you still have the same
core four right you've got you got warm
Outreach you've got cold Outreach you've
got paid ads and then you've got um I
should know these I wrote the book okay
organic content right so these are the
these are the four things that you can
do right and then you've got head
hunters right which is basically
recruiters um and you have uh Word of
Mouth from your existing oops Word of
Mouth from your resisting staff and so
these are the ways that you can get um
physical therapists and so we have to
approach this the same way we approach
getting customers they are just now the
customer and so um maybe running in dads
is probably not the way that's that
you're going to get them but I'll bet
you that Outreach will work
exceptionally well um to get therapists
and I would probably bet that if you had
a really good referral incentive um over
time that would compound now small not
as much you'll probably need to do this
to start as you get bigger though
there's going to be enough of a base
where a few percentage every month of
referral girls is material and so let me
just put this in math for you so that
you can so this will motivate you to do
it how much do you make in gross profit
off of a physical therapist per year on
average about 350
okay so if I told you that I could add
$350,000 in gross profit per year to
your business how much would you be
willing to pay for that in the first
year quite a lot right and so giving
someone $500 for referral not that
motivating if you said I'll give you 20
grand for a referral I'll bet you'll get
them to
move most businesses are either comp
Supply constrained or demand constrained
now if you have a business that's both
then it's like you don't have customers
you don't have employees like that's a
tough place to be most of the time it's
one or the other and what's interesting
is that entrepreneurs will often try and
solve basically like not solve the real
problem and this was kind of exact what
she was presenting with she was like
should I do this other thing or should I
like should I should I change my model
all together but the crazy thing is just
like her model was doing great she was
making good margins she had she's doing
good Revenue out of two locations it's
like why are we going to break the model
like the constraint of the business is
that you just don't know how to recruit
so let's just solve that problem because
her other path of like just raising
prices which to be fair I'm all in favor
of at some point it's like you can't
raise the prices anymore like you're
becoming like a luxury business and it's
just like you're changing all the
Dynamics of the business but her
business worked already and so for me
the lowest risk thing to do is not
change the business model but just
figure out the problem of the business
and solve it and for her biggest problem
was I can't get people but I don't think
she had Quantified how much she should
be willing to invest in getting more
talent and I think this is wildly
underrated it's like think about it from
a return on on profit I only did it on
gross profit right it was $350,000 per
employee so I'm like why would you not
pay I mean like just being real why
would you not pay $50,000 or $100,000
right if you know that if I people are
happy to put you know $100,000 in the
stock market and get 10% back and make
10,000 but in their businesses they're
hesitant to give a commission of of
$110,000 for $300,000 thing right and so
if you're like well what if that doesn't
work out then push it out where there's
a contingency that you're happy to do it
and if you want keep raising the price
until you get people to refer like with
enough incentive you can move the world
and So speaking of this Physical Therapy
brick and mortar business uh I did a
brick-and-mortar breakdown of five
locations of caropractor that had done
through m&a uh on how to accelerate the
growth of the business and it's super
tactical and it works whether you have a
single location or you're even virtual a
lot of the Tactical carry over to any
business to help it grow enjoy